my fellow Americans not long ago I received a
letter from a woman in the Midwest she wrote
yeah mr. president in my humble way I'm writing to
you about the crisis in Vietnam I have a son who
is now in Vietnam my husband served in World
War two our country was at war but now this
time it's just something that I don't understand
why [Music] eunuch 1938 German Chancellor Adolf
Hitler arrives for a conference to be held here
with British Prime Minister Neville Chamberlain
[Music] this meeting will long be
remembered for it opens the door
to the dreams of dictatorship we regard
the agreement signed last night and the
anglo-german naval agreement as symbolic of
the desire of our two peoples never to go to
war with one another again peace in our time
[Music] a shortcut to disaster but even then
this was no new lesson if it's Tara's
in the face with Mussolini in Ethiopia
[Music] Ethiopia's emperor haile selassie made
his protest to the League of Nations but nothing
was done we'd also seen the young horses in
Austria and nothing was done then in 1950 [Music]
aggression was again Unleashed this
time across the 38th parallel in
Korea but freemen had begun to run
the lesson and something was done
the lesson had been learned and President
Johnson had phrased its meaning well aggression
unchallenged is aggression unleashed why must
join Americans born into a land exultant with
hope and with golden promise toil and suffer
and sometimes die in such a remote and distant
place the answer like the war itself is not
an easy one but it echoes clearly from the
painful lessons of half a century three times
in my lifetime in two world wars and in Korea
Americans have gone too far our lands to
fight for freedom we have learned that
a terrible and a brutal cost that retreat
does not bring safety and weakness does not
bring peace and it is this lesson that
has brought us to Vietnam for the back